in the world of music journalism the
names don't get much bigger than Rolling
Stone magazine co-founder and publisher
yan winter as rolling stone marks its
50th anniversary an eagerly awaited
biography of winter has now been
published sticky fingers the life and
times of Yan winner and Rolling Stone
magazine is the product of hours of
interviews with winner and exclusive
access to the magazine's archives and
we're joined by the author Joe Hagin Joe
good morning good morning thanks for
having me you spent a hundred hours
interviewing Yan winner for this book
yeah he gave you his blessing initially
yes and then decided he hated this yes
it's true what happened well listen you
know his expectations for what book
should be and what the book were I guess
obviously diverged she wanted a more
reverent account of what had happened
and I wrote kind of the full true story
which is a lot more complicated and
messy and rock-and-roll story it's a
rock and roll type definition it's messy
absolutely absolutely so this is someone
who had personal relationships with the
Giants of rock and roll you delved deep
into his personal archives
what story surprised you the most I
think I was surprised by how the
personal story is translated to what
people read in the magazine his
relationships with John Lennon and Mick
Jagger people don't understand how kind
of hand-in-glove some of these
relationships were how they were social
relationships and those translated to
Mick Jagger having more covers than
anybody else and so you know in the name
Rolling Stone in the band The Rolling
Stones there was a copyright business
issue there and that translated into 50
years of a relationship and John Lennon
didn't like the fact that he thought it
was a shout-out to the Rolling Stones
any that's right and there so all these
like kind of petty grievances and
betrayals and all these personal stories
translated to what people read in the
magazine and so that was to me really
exciting to write about what's
interesting is is his winter came along
right during the Monterey Pop Festival
essentially he actually was working
there a little bit yes saw what was
happening and he he saw he saw a market
for a magazine that the treated this
this culture seriously that's right and
he created a window into it for the rest
of the world who everybody was
fascinated to what was what was
in San Francisco this rock-and-roll
Renaissance and he drove his essential
vision was that he knew that this could
be taken to the mainstream that the
rock-and-roll generation was going to
take over and they did and he tracks at
Rolling Stone tracked the rock-and-roll
generation as they went to Hollywood to
Washington and you know for 50 years
they were going to take over until you
get to Bill Clinton in the White House
you know the consummate baby boomer and
as beyond what's too how did someone who
is a dropout from Berkeley no real
business experience end up founding an
empire that's lasted almost half a
century well listen he had a lot of
hustle he was very rude understand he
was a workaholic and he was obsessive
all the kind of traits of an
entrepreneur and you know entrepreneurs
were not common among counterculture
world you know hippies and a lot of
drugs and everything he was able to kind
of survive in that world and guide it
and Shepherd it and be the gatekeeper of
it ultimately well it's interesting cuz
he really wanted I mean you point this
out in the book he wanted to take the
counterculture mainstream he wanted to
me he wanted to he was a mainstream
person he was not a hippie himself he
was a preppy rich really originally and
he was essentially a social climber he
was somebody that wanted to be where
there was fame and stardom and money and
he saw that rock and roll was going
there but this seems to be the heart of
his objection to your portrayal of him
Joe which is I mean I interviewed him
for Sunday morning and whatever seemed
to bristle at the most yeah was that you
hold him responsible in part for the
growth of the celebrity culture right
and I will I stand by that
and listen Rolling Stone and People
magazine were the two most popular
magazines of the 1970s they pioneered as
and reinvented what celebrity was around
the youth culture around to the new
generation and they had different values
than had what had come before and their
values were sexuality and confession and
all the things that we know now to be
just commonplace aspects of celebrity
and later yan published Us Weekly I mean
think about where we are today in our
culture and some of the values of the
celebrity world well some of those were
very familiar to Yan and in Rolling
Stone was there at the beginning but
Yuans ambition complicated a lot of his
very
relationships did it not absolutely I
mean listen it's it's ambition is in the
title of my book and this is a what his
life was about you know he wanted to be
at the center of the action wherever it
was and he would have relationships with
people like Mick Jagger and on the one
hand Mick Jagger wants to be on the
cover of Rolling Stone
but he might not like the treatment that
Yann gives him and so you're gonna have
a complicated dance there with all of
these major figures and they needed him
and he needed them and it was a soap
opera man the book is sticky fingers the
life and times of young winner in
Rolling Stone magazine and it is a
fascinating right the delicious it sure
is Joe Hagen thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me